papa
on m'a dit deux jours avant sa mort que
dans deux jours tu souhaites mort
toujours avant d'être heureux tu aimais
les filles d'aimer leurs yeux
tu as pris les choses en main ne se bat
pour savoir si tu avais des chats et
chattes en avait pas comme ça au moins
jeunes et mangeraient pas
et puis je me suis épuisé à convaincre
tu as bien aimé toujours c'est trop
court trop court pour se marier
je plains
m
qui
bah
bâti deux heures après ta mort il ya
deux heures dont bell est mort deux
heures avant j'étais heureux j'ai mis
une fille jamais ses yeux
j'ai pris les choses en main de ce parc
voir ce qui restait de toi
soit il reste que moi mais ça aussi ça
durera pas
et puis je me suis épuisé à convaincre
ma bien aimée le jour c'est trop court
ça sert à rien de se marier
je pleure
car je t'aime
qui
de plus
moi jamais mais pas
le
bâtie trente ans après ma mort mon fils
a dit que j'étais mal
j'étais pas
que j'étais mort
nicole